I think humans really have a deep desire
for meaning and it's something that is
really hardwired into us so if you look
at an infant who's just learning about
the world that infant needs to learn
rules of cause and effect you know what
happens you start sometimes see babies
and they keep dropping objects and you
think it's so incredibly annoying you
say stop dropping that you know I just
picked it up for you
they're learning about physics they're
actually really curious to see that
every time they drop it it falls that is
a totally amazing and mesmerizing new
concept if you think about it so we
start looking for cause and effect right
away that's how we make sense of the
world and as you grow older you're still
looking for that cause and effect that's
saying you know if I cry mommy comes
back cause leads directly to effect an
event leads directly to what that event
causes we are really uncomfortable when
that's not the case and the world is
really really messy you know it's not
all about the dropping a ball and it
falls the world really is all about
uncertainty it's ambiguous causes don't
leave to affect things just happen
without any action on your part
sometimes you take an action and nothing
happens even though you want it to
happen so there are there are lots of
gaps in meaning because that meaning
that we want to be there is not there
and we still search for it and so we
still want that meaning to be there we
want certainty we want to resolve that
ambiguity and con-artists that's what
they do
they resolve it for us they give us
meaning that's why I think the the same
principles that underlie cons are the
principles that Organa that organized
religion follows because you have
spontaneous organized religion in
societies throughout the world you see
it throughout history over and over
religion just keeps popping up because
once again it also gives meaning and
explains things and gives people a
purpose and that's what that's what con
artists do they sell meaning they sell
purpose there's a saying that's kind of
out in the ether and there are lots of
varieties of it but it goes something
like this
religion emerged when the first
scoundrel met the first fool and this
has been attributed to Voltaire to Mark
Twain to Carl Sagan I mean it's been
attributed to just a
anyone who had a problem with organized
religion and it seems to make a lot of
sense because here you have someone who
wants meaning who wants some sort of
depth to life and then you have someone
who sees that and says uh-huh
that's an opportunity for me I'm smart I
know that life is meaningless I know
that all this stuff doesn't mean
anything I know that you know there's no
afterlife there's no this there's no
that let me see what would make this
person feel better and if that person
feels better you know what's gonna
happen that person's gonna give me money
because he's going to be so grateful for
feeling better that I'll be able to
elicit donations I'll be respected I
will be a person of great esteem in
society and there you have an opening
and there you have the first priest and
I say priest in a in a very broad way
priest of any religion or any spiritual
movement or a cult leader by the way
cults are the most profound and
terrifying cons there are because that's
your spiritual con that's someone who
tricks you into joining something that's
going to take over your life even though
you have no idea that that's what you're
joining it's very clear what that with
the intentionality behind that original
quote is because if there's an opening
someone is going to take that opening
most people are not scoundrels but there
are plenty of scoundrels out there and
it certainly doesn't help us that we are
all basically hardwired to trust other
people we're really bad at spotting
deception and you actually see over the
course of history that societies with
greater levels of trust end up being
societies that develop more that are
economically sounder that have better
social institutions and on an individual
level you see people with higher levels
of trust you see them usually being
smarter getting ahead more in terms of
their professional careers being happier
being healthier and it makes a lot of
sense because for society to get ahead
you need to and build that society how
does society get formed through human
connections
through bonds through people trusting
one another working together actually
building institutions how do people get
ahead once again through social
connections you don't get ahead on your
own and so we we end up trusting and
that plays into our wanting to believe
even more and so con artists just have a
field day